we have executive director and
international arbiter Grantchester
consultant or ms where I will forfeit
you know seriously a friend of ours here
at the st. Louis chess club
Tony rich to talk about all the exciting
events that are happening in the coming
year and when she says Fred she means
boss boss because he's the boss man
director of the st. Louis chess club I
don't know how many hours are in his day
maybe 24 hours an hours but Tony you get
a lot of stuff done welcome to the show
thanks Maurice the calendar is packed
this year it usually is pretty full but
what the heck it just exploded this year
you know it's funny we always add
tournaments and we never take away it
used to be that the Chess Club slow
season was this time of year the January
February March but we really do have a
very full schedule
not just with events here at the club
but also the grand chest or tournaments
as well tell me this one when it was
first conceived how'd you feel about it
you know the Karen's cup was always very
important to us
Jennifer shadi spent such a great
partner to the Chess Club since the very
first u.s. women's championship that we
held and I know that it's been a big
initiative for her as well so for the
club to be able to host a tournament
like this to promote the top women in
the world and to spotlight these players
to all the young girls here in st. Louis
and around the world it's a dream come
true for us and right after this we get
the champion showdown that's right
champion showdown $300,000 prize fund
the big five all of the Americans that
are rated over 2700 against some well
selected opponents I think it's going to
be exciting you you added I see a long
list here on the monitor you you added
all the Americans rated over twenty
seven hundred five players who's that
fifth player we know Shanklin became
them before that's right number five
actually is the newest American chess
player it's lennier Dominguez who's
transfer just went through right around
Christmastime from Cuba that's right
all right so American chess got even
just got even stronger absolutely
amazing
now tell us some more about these other
events we see we saw on the list we got
the Spring Classic coming up yeah so the
classic tournaments I can tell you about
we have four of those a year spring
summer fall and winter those are to ten
player round robins to
we usually the top section have a net
has an average rating over 20 650 in
fact the spring classic that's coming up
in March we have this Iliev on truck and
laQuan liam both times so two 2700
players for the first time for those of
us junkies go to V in st. Louis that's
right it's his first time here you know
I've got my wish list of players that I
want to see play here in st. Louis and
have on truck is definitely top though
Wow I mean this list already looks like
a lot for a single club and it's only
till July that's right so the US
collegiate rabbit and blitz championship
is right after the Spring Classic that's
a new US chess sanction event giving
away national titles to collegiate
players we followed up with the u.s. and
women's championship same 12 player
format that we've gone with the past few
years as well and then we go through the
rest of the summer as well and then we
see now going into the fall know this
little thing called the st. Louis travel
but oh and the sink fill cup I wonder
who's gonna show up to that event yeah I
think those are pretty strong
tournaments typically and then a
champion showdown you're looking at
chess960 in them and the classics as you
said a very busy schedule and that's
just here in the club but you guys also
have to work because of the Grantchester
events that are happening all over the
world just like you guys absolutely so
we are happy to be able to produce the
commentary here in st. Louis your fans
know one love you guys and want to see
all the action called by the best
commentators as Rex puts it so what
better way to do that then to have the
studio up and running here for all of
the grand chest Tour events so if that
was all it'll be good but you also have
Scholastic chess as well over 140
schools now that you're teaching it
right so one of the great things about
the chess club here in st. Louis is
we're not just a chess club we kind of
take the three main program areas that
lots of folks focus on major events
scholastic chess and the club the
community center for everybody and we
combine it into one organization so like
you mentioned scholastic chest more than
a hundred schools right now
you know programming is is amazing there
you see some of the photos here that's
at st. Louis University we regularly get
more than 200 students from around the
st. Louis area at all of our scholastic
tournaments and they just you can tell
that they're in love with the game they
absolutely are enamored and whenever
they get the chance to meet the Fabiano
car you wanna Zoar the or the Magnus
Carlson's when they're here in st. Louis
it does nothing but help build the chest
community in st. Louis
Wow just I'm tired just hearing all this
stuff being described and yet and I'm
also inspired as well and there's going
to be a very inspiring event with the
police officers playing against students
in the community tell us about that
program sure this kind of goes back a
few years to the Ferguson riots that
happened here in st. Louis one of the
things that city leaders identified is
that there's a real disconnect between
st. Louis police officers and st. Louis
community members and so one of the ways
that we're trying to break down some of
those barriers and and let people know
that we're all just people we all come
from backgrounds and we all are just
normal folks so on Monday the rest day
for the Karen's Cup Monday February 11th
from 9:00 to 11:00 a.m. we'll be kicking
off the chess cops program now this is a
program where police officers and st.
Louis and surrounding areas will go into
schools and they'll actually teach
students how to play the game of chess
in uniform so not only is that a good
opportunity for kids to learn how to
play but it breaks down those those
barriers that intimidation that you
might feel around police officers and
makes them feel more like a friend than
a adversary pretty inspiring stuff great
work amazing stuff you do here at the
club and I'm honored to be a part of it
thank you very much for your
contribution thanks Bree appreciate Tony
yeah I won't let you go again as I as
were commentators and we had a breakfast
together all of us the other day and it
was mentioned that while we're doing the
English broadcast where this Karen's Cup
and there's a Russian broadcast you're
actually thinking of a studio see that
you what's up with that letters in the
alphabet you know so more language is
the number of the alphabets so the
commentary that we do here is fantastic
but we really want to expand our
audience we want to broaden our
footprint within the chess community but
more importantly than that we really
want to reach non chess players too one
of the ways that we can do that is by
adding additional commentary so as folks
know we're doing Russian commentary in
addition to the English commentary for
the Karen's Cup oftentimes for the US
Championships we'll have Spanish and
English commentary so we always look to
mix it up and try to find a new audience
try to bring more folks in who maybe
haven't heard about the same those chess
club before
Tony one event that I'm really excited
about that you added to the calendar is
the u.s. senior clothes championship
what a great addition allowing some of
these you know amazing players like
Benjamin and Christensen who used to get
invited as one of the top seeds the u.s.
championship and now of course it's it's
a deal is yes us chess has been such a
great partner with us Jennifer's so
Carol Meyer at u.s. chess who's their
executive director you guys have spoken
with her here has approved a bid for a
new event so far they're only two senior
events on the calendar in the United
States there's the Senior Open in the
senior tournament of champions so this
is now a new tournament it's a senior
closed championship or Invitational ten
player round-robin $50,000 prize fund
commentary and the whole shebang that
goes along with it
and Yasir I hope to see you playing here
at a Tony are over that's right over 50
yeah it's a very sprightly senior fifty
years old yeah I think I think Marissa
actually may be able to challenge
grabbing that price